[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
der Valentinstag rückt immer näher und
deswegen gibt es natürlich von mir
wieder einen wundervolles Rezept viele
weitere Rezepte findet ihr schon auf
meinem Kanal aber ich kann vom
Valentinstag gar nicht genug kriegen
weil ich so viel Liebe für dich
der unnötigste Tag des Jahres wirklich
ohne Spaß ja das stimmt aber ich finde
es irgendwie trotzdem süß weil man dann
anfängt mit lauter Herzchen und süßen
Sachen auch wieder ein zusätzliches Tag
schön heute gibt's Valentinstags
Törtchen in Form von kleinen Tablets ich
glaube ein bisschen finde
nein nicht wirklich nicht aber es ist
mir einfach zu viel Liebe im Raum ja
weitere Videos seht ja wohl nicht jetzt
kurz verrühren und dann kommt das Mehl
mit den übrigen Zutaten dazu
und den Teig einfach nicht zu lange
kneten das ist ein Mürbeteig und der
muss schön kalt bleiben
[Musik]
manchmal wenn die Butter noch ganz ganz
kalt ist dann kann es passieren dass der
Teig nicht sofort wie ein Teig
zusammenkommt ist aber gar nicht schlimm
denn dann braucht er nur so ein bisschen
Handwärme und dann könnt ihr ihn nämlich
zu einer Kugel formen flachdrücken und
abgedeckt im Kühlschrank etwa eine
Stunde ruhen lassen damit sich da auch
der ganze Zucker auflösen kann
hier habe ich jetzt den Mürbeteig den
habe ich einmal kurz durchgeknetet dann
ist das schön geschmeidig zum Ausrollen
und ich nehme jetzt gleich meine
minitablett Förmchen auch die haben
tatsächlich einen Hebeboden damit man
auch Mini Tablets schön aus der Form
rausbekommt aber ihr könnt auch gerne
eine Tarte damit zubereiten falls ihr
keine Tablet Förmchen habt jetzt rollt
ihr den Teig
etwa 3 mm dünn aus
einfach mit etwas Mehl
mein Sofa ist kein Kratzbaum
sagst du jetzt habe ich zwei Kinder und
beide sind schon aus dem Gröbsten raus
ne 12 Jahre 7 Jahre jetzt habe ich zwei
Katzen
[Musik]
das ist kein Kratzbaum Muffins
im Hause ist immer was zu erleben
okay also drei Millimeter dünn
die tablettförmchen werden dann
eingefettet mit backtrennspray da immer
drauf achten die Dose senkrecht halten
jetzt schaut ihr nach der Größe also
entweder nehmt ihr euch die Form legt
sie hin und schneidet so ein Zentimeter
drumherum weg oder ihr nehmt euch zum
Beispiel einen Teller oder eine Backform
so wie jetzt hier diesen bisschen größer
passt
und dann kann man damit die Kreise schön
ausstechen
und dann schön in die Form reinlegen und
den Rand mit einer Palette am besten
abstreifen
und dann schön von innen nach außen
[Musik]
yeah
perfekt
[Musik]
alle sechs auf einmal backen können
schade dass ich niemanden kennen mit
einem Backshop
[Musik]
naja vor dem Backen stelle ich die noch
mal ganz kurz ins Gefrierfach oder ihr
könnt auch im Kühlschrank stellen
natürlich dann werden sie gebacken denn
so behalten sie ihre Form viel besser
ich habe jetzt noch drei übrig das heißt
aus denen aus dem bekomme ich jetzt
glaube ich noch drei bis vier hin aber
ich muss jetzt nacheinander Backen ich
habe noch viel Tabletten
[Musik]
so jetzt sind sie gebacken und weil ich
es jetzt nicht blind gebacken habe das
heißt kein Backpapier rein mit schweren
Hülsenfrüchten heben sie sich so ein
bisschen überbacken ist aber gar nicht
schlimm denn dann nimmt ihr einfach ein
Glas direkt nach dem Backen so ein
bisschen flachdrücken
und am Rande festdrücken und dann
auskühlen lassen dann sind sie auch
perfekt ohne dass man mit Hülsenfrüchten
was backen muss
nicht vergessen ab dem 17 Februar bin
ich jeden Freitag live bei RTL bei Let's
Dance dabei unterstützt mich dabei ich
brauche eure Anrufe und eure Stimmen der
nicht tanzt schon ganz fleißig für euch
die Tablets sind gebacken und ich habe
sie abkühlen lassen das habe ich gestern
Abend noch gemacht und dann habe ich sie
einfach im Kühlschrank gestellt damit
sie gut abkühlen insgesamt habe ich
jetzt sechs Stück ich zeige euch auch
gleich wie ich sie rauslöse die anderen
habe ich hier schon rausgelöst und jetzt
geht's an die Füllung und ich habe mir
jetzt überlegt dass wir Panna Cotta
Tartes machen mit Erdbeeren und
Himbeeren weil sie eine tolle Farbe
ergeben und für mich Valentinstag immer
so ein bisschen was rosa rotes hat also
immer so bisschen Herz und rosa
Erdbeeren es gibt gerade noch keine
frischen Erdbeeren gibt's schon aber
keine saisonalen deswegen habe ich jetzt
hier tiefgefrorene Produkte ihr könnt
entweder nur Erdbeeren oder nur
Himbeeren nehmen aber ich finde die
Kombi eigentlich echt schon ganz gut für
die Füllung verwende ich jeweils 100 g
Himbeeren und Erdbeer die sind aus dem
Tiefkühlfach etwas Zitronensaft fünf
Gramm aber etwas Vanilleextrakt 80g
Zucker und 300 g Sahne
stelle ich mal kurz zur Seite das
rauslösen zeige ich euch gleich jetzt
geht es eigentlich echt ganz einfach
denn ihr packt alle Zutaten so wie sie
hier sind in einen Mixer und püriert
alles miteinander
sich gar nicht eine andere Arbeit machen
sondern alles hier rein und dann kommt
es in den Topf das Agar-Agar ist quasi
ein pflanzliches Bindemittel des Pendant
zu gelatine ist Agartine oder Agar Agar
und damit wird es dann in den Topf
umgefüllt ich lasse es zwei Minuten lang
sprudeln und kochen und dann ist die
Müll Füllung schon fertig also mehr muss
man da gar nicht machen
nur ein bisschen Zitronensaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
richtig leckerer Milkshake
ist es im Prinzip auch nur mit Sahne
eben und dann mit dem Schneebesen rühren
aufkochen lassen und 2 Minuten sprudeln
kochen lassen das ist auch wichtig damit
das Agar-Agar eben auch gut wirken kann
ich stelle mir hier auch wirklich immer
schön den Wecker also hier auf dem
Kochfeld ihr könnt auch das Handy nehmen
z.B aber 2 Minuten später lassen ist
wirklich ganz wichtig damit die Masse
fest wird und sobald der Herd ausgeht
das geht jetzt in 50 Sekunden lasse ich
es ganz kurz abkühlen und ich mache auch
direkt eine Gelierprobe ich kontrolliere
quasi immer ob die Masse auch wirklich
fest wird wenn sie abkühlt und nehme mir
gleich dafür dieses kleine Schälchen da
kommt so ein Esslöffel voll rein ich
kann den Kühlschrank stellen und während
das hier dann nämlich lauwarm abkühlt
kann ich dann schon sehen ob es
funktioniert da kann man immer so ein
bisschen prüfen ob es auch bindet bevor
man es dann eben einfüllt weil dann ist
zu spät wenn es nicht findet
die Gelierprobe ist geglückt
blöderweise habe ich sie aufgegangen
ich habe es einfach aufgegessen okay ich
habe jetzt hier meine sechs Törtchen
jetzt hier vorsichtig rauslösen
schaut mal deswegen habe ich ja da unten
diesen Hebeboden wir nehmen es in die
Hand und drückt vorsichtig mit den
Fingern raus ich drehe das immer gerne
so ein bisschen dann weiß ich es löst
sich überall
ganz vorsichtig sein die müssen
natürlich komplett abgekühlt sein und
jetzt habe ich hier den Boden jetzt
vorsichtig arbeiten den so an einer
Stelle lupfen und am besten legt ihr es
ab dann kann schon mal nichts kaputt
gehen
kann ich jetzt hier die lauwarme Masse
rein füllen ich mache das jetzt mit
einem Eisportionierer könnt auch eine
Dosierflasche nehmen oder mit Trichter
einfach vorsichtig das darf jetzt auch
nicht mehr zu heiß sein
perfekt ein mittlerer Eisportionierer
groß
[Musik]
wunderschön wunderschön
da ist natürlich wichtig dass die
Mürbeteig Tablets keine Risse haben
damit das ganze nicht unten ausläuft ich
habe auch kurz gebackt denn hier bei
mittleren waren kleiner Riss aber so ist
aussieht
jetzt ganz gut ihr könnt natürlich auch
Nummer sicher gehen und könnt zwei drei
mehr backen
so wie ich es getan habe denn mir ist
beim rauslösen sind mit zwei gebrochen
ist aber nicht schlimm ich habe dann
einfach noch mal Teig gemacht also geht
lieber auf Nummer sicher macht die
doppelte Menge Teig und dann habt ihr
auf jeden Fall so viele wie ihr braucht
aber die Menge an sich reicht für sechs
Stück aus wobei die Füllung für acht
ausreicht ich mache die jetzt auch
gleich noch fertig und dann kommen sie
in den Kühlschrank können schön fest
werden habe ich denn jetzt kaputt
gemacht
im Kühlschrank fest werden und dann
dekoriere ich sie fertig really hat es
jetzt sein müssen hat das jetzt sein
müssen
und stell dir einfach mal kalt
[Musik]
jetzt in die Törtchen fest und werden
fertig dekoriert und zwar habe ich dafür
etwas weiße Kuvertüre bereits
geschmolzen in einem Spritzbeutel dann
habe ich Gefrage getrocknete Himbeeren
ein paar crispress in weiß und ein
bisschen Baiser Drops und etwas
jetzt mal Valenta valent
valentinstagsmäßig schön wow
okay also ich würde damit anfangen das
hier so ein bisschen drüber zu Dritteln
[Musik]
Himbeeren kann man dann schön drüber
bröseln
[Musik]
sie Drops und den Streusel drauf
zum probieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist doch süß ich weiß du würdest das
jetzt normalerweise in die Hand nehmen
einfach reinbeißer so richtig Runden mit
unsieren
keine frischen Erdbeeren hat zur
Valentinstags Zeit gefroren
ganz cool ehrlich
bei uns im Shop
weil man dann ich meine das war gerade
eben innerhalb von einer halben Minute
dekoriert okay also richtig cool also
echt ganz ganz cool für die Valentinstag
und für alle die ist das schöne ist wenn
man noch mehr Liebe zu verteilen hat als
nur an eine Person kann man diese
Törtchen ja auch wunderbar Teilen man
kann so viele Törtchen verschenken ihr
könnt sehen
mein Gott
also verbreitet eure Liebe in Form von
Herzchen Lidl
also macht's gut bis zum nächsten mal
schön Valentinstag und ich liebe dich
okay viel Spaß tschüss ich ich schaffe
dich ab einem gewissen Alter schaffe ich
nicht mehr diese Euphorie für
Valentinstag
das hat nichts mit dem Alter zu tun ja
die Bauchbinde Murat der Valentinstags
Grinch gezogen
tschüss
[Musik]
[Applaus]